Hi Sarah!
I’m Marcia Boardman – we spoke on the
phone...
Oh yes, I remember – I was having a bad
day!
...and this is Philip Hart, our CEO.
Hello!
Hello, it’s very nice to meet you both.
It says on your CV that you do voluntary work...
Well, when I have time, yes!
I do work at a centre for children with difficulties,
yes...
That must be very interesting...
It’s rewarding and challenging.
Sarah, can you tell us a little bit about
your current position?
Sarah: I’m assistant sales director for
a chain of language schools.
So this post would be quite a change then...
I don’t think so honestly because the skills
are the same, despite the product.
Why are you thinking of moving on?
Well I’ve come as far as I can in my current
position, I feel and I’m 28 now and would
love to take on some more responsibility.
Ok, let’s move on to managing people.
Can you give us an example of when you had
to deal with a particularly difficult managee?
Well, yes, I had two people working for me
who didn’t get along at all – they had
no shared values, different temperaments – and
they used to argue a lot, it looked like it
was impossible for them to work together.
So, I sat down with them, and we talked about
their differences and their problems and after
that, things went much more smoothly!
How would you deal with a rapidly changing
and uncertain global market?
Ok, that’s actually something I wanted to
talk about in my presentation...but I’d
say to stay flexible and to diversify markets
and sales strategies.
It says on your CV you speak French and Spanish.
Yes, I do.
I lived in both France and Spain for a while.
Any plans to learn other languages?
I’d love to try!
Ok, can you tell us about a time you had to
close a particularly challenging deal?
Well, the biggest contract I won - and the
thing I’m most proud of professionally - was
with a large university in India, to provide
language training.
The contract was full of technicalities and
the client was very picky!
– But I still pulled it off.
Ok – do you have any questions for us?
Yes - about your ethical policy and your carbon
footprint...I was wondering whether you are
planning to reduce your carbon footprint and
whether all your products are ethically sourced?
That’s a very good question...and that’s
something we’re moving towards at the moment...
Ok, well, let’s move on to the presentation...